[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pour un nouveau numéro
de 100 % Sénat l'émission qui vous fait
vivre les travaux de la Haute Assemblée
le Sénat a organisé la semaine dernière
une table ronde sur l'intelligence
artificielle l'occasion de voir comment
ces nouvelles technologies bouleversese
actuellement le secteur du numérique au
niveau mondial et puis les sénateurs ont
également posé la question de la place
de la France et de l'Europe dans le
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle je vous laisse écouter
cette table ronde le thème que vous
souhaitez aborder avec nous consiste à
un panorama des enjeux des puissances
dans le monde numérique les puissances
économique et l'innovation la
souveraineté et la résilience les modèle
politique et normatif et tout ce que
vous vourez bien nous dire ce soir ainsi
bien sûr qu'un point de vue sur les
forces et faiblesses françaises en
matière d'IRA vousai également je crois
les risques de dépendance européenne
technologique vis-à-vis des autres
grandes puissances je vous laisse donc
la parole merci monsieur le sénateur
merci aux organisateurs pour
l'invitation et merci vous dans cette
salle qui êtes resté pour pour cette
dernière table ronde alors j'ai un petit
peu changé je suis désolée le
l'organisation de mon propos qui va
rebondir finalement sur pas mal de
choses qui ont été dites au cours de
cette journée euh lorsqu'il s'agit
d'examiner les forces et faiblesses de
la France et de l'Europe dans dans le
numérique et plus précisément
l'intelligence artificielle question est
déjà suffisamment large rien quand on se
consacre à la dimension Ia par rapport à
la Chine aux États-Unis et cetera et la
question de même de de quoi relève la
puissance numérique
euh je
propose l'approche suivante qui est et
ça rejoindra des choses qui ont été
dites déjà précédemment qui est que
l'intelligence artificielle n'est pas
séparée du reste de l'écosystème et de
la chaîne de valeur
numérique et que dès lors les politiques
dans l'intelligence artificielle y
compris les politiques publiques doivent
être pensé en lien avec un ensemble
d'autres problématiques relevant de la
recherche des infrastructure moyen
d'entraînement de la puissance de calcul
des puces et autres semiconducteurs mais
également du
Cloud et enfin des enjeux qui ont été
très brièvement évoqués mais sur
lesquels je m'étendrai un peu plus
relevant de l'open source et des
opportunités qui se présentent à travers
l'OP source pour développer
d'intelligence artificielle évidemment
il faut également prendre en compte mais
ça je le traiterai pas dans mon propos
la question de la protection des données
de la régulation des financements et des
talents je pense que peut-être ce sera
évoqué par les autres intervenants de la
table ronde mais donc je vais me
concentrer sur cet enjeu de la chaîne de
valeur on va dire quasiment matérielle
de l'intelligence artificielle comment
faire en sorte d'avoir les
infrastructures et les capacités
nécessaires pour être à la hauteur de la
compétition internationale dans
l'IA je dirais pour commencer que les
choses vont plutôt dans le bon sens on a
eu des discours un peu déftistes quand
même au cours de cette journée y compris
dans la précédente table ronde mais il y
a eu des progrès ces dernières années en
France et en Europe même si des défis
persistent évidemment concernant la
dimension de la recherche en IA ça a été
évoqué un petit peu au début de journée
les technologies émergant dont
l'intelligence artificielle sont le
résultat d'une recherche de long terme
donc ça a été dit par rapport à open a
et Chad GPT on a eu l'impression que ça
sortait de nulle part alors qu'en fait
c'est un le résultat de d'années de
recherche et cette recherche pendant
longtemps a été mené dans un contexte
académique recherche académique qui
repose sur la publication des résultats
la reproduction des expériences
l'évaluation par les paires la
circulation des chercheurs et la
collaboration
internationale cette ouverture de la
recherche permet l'attraction des
meilleurs talents et également d'ment
temp à augmenter la qualité et l'impact
de la recherche or on constate qu'on est
face à une évolution des écosystèmes de
recherche en IA euh on a entendu
d'ailleurs en début journée les propos
de Joë baral de Google c'est assez
représentatif de qui fait la recherche
en IA aujourd'hui bien évidemment on
constate que les auteurs et autrices
d'articles académiques les plus notables
à l'échelle mondiale sont aujourd'hui
presque tous affiliés à l'industrie ou
dans des équipes mixte de recherche avec
une inversion des ratios entre le la
recherche publique et la recherche
privée qui s'est effectué en 2018 avec
une inversion de ratio vraiment très
significative évidemment ça est dû à
l'attractivité des bigtech donc des
grandes entreprises notamment américaine
qui propose des salaires des capacités
de calcul et un accès à des données qui
sont très attractifs pour tout chercheur
qui veut développer des capacités de
logicel en IA à titre d'exemple google
publie plusieurs centaines d'articles
par an et une entreprise comme Valeo qui
est le premier déposant de brevet en
France et qui a une branche Valeo Ia qui
fait du logiciel d'intelligence
artificielle pour la conduite autonome
euh publie environ 30 articles par an
donc plusieurs centaines côté Google 30
côté valaleéo c'est pas très surprenant
comme ordre de grandeur mais c'est
toujours bien d'avoir ça en tête or
quand on a une recherche qui est faite
par le secteur privé on n pas les
conditions que j'évoqué au début de la
recherche publique ouverte et de la
publication euh et de Laur
productibilité des expériences et cetera
il y a des limites aux publications qui
sont fixées par l'industrie en fonction
de leurs intérêts propres alors parfois
ils vont publier certains papiers quand
c'est utile pour eux soit parce qu'ils
ont fait de la recherche vraiment
purement fondamentale qui n'est pas
applicable sur des enjeux éthiques de
l'IA entre autres que fait par exemple
Google mais ils vont aussi choisir de ne
pas publier ce qui serait peut-être
stratégique pour eux à inclure dans leur
produits et on a vu que par exemple
Google a décidé de limiter drastiquement
ce qu'il publie depuis l'émergence de
chat GPT puisque le ti de de GPT c'est
transformer et c'est issu d'un papier de
Google qui était sorti je pense en 2017
euh là où on voit aussi les délais hein
de de la recherche en IA et qui a permis
à a de développer son chat GPT et
ensuite de concurrencer le Bard de
Google donc on a un problème de
transparence sur les les progrès
technologiques en fait on a une
visibilité assez limitée dans la mesure
où la recherche est faite par
l'industrie et et cette cette enjeu de à
quelle finalité sont publié les les
recherches souvent dans des finalités
plutôt de l'ordre de la communication
voire voire du
marketing ce cette problématique de la
privatisation de la recherche dans l'IA
est aussi dû au fait que les nécessités
en terme de capacité de calcul sont
telles que selon les chiffres que j'ai
trouvé les les capacités requises pour
mener des grandes expériences en IA ont
augmenté de plus de 300000 fois au cours
d'une décennie he la puissance de calcul
nécessaire cette augmentation des
ressources nécessaires pour entraîner
les logiciels les algorithmes d'IA a
entraîné par ricochet une baisse
significative des contributions purement
académiques à ses expériences qui sont
passées de 60 60 % à presque zéro en 10
an
euh bon la privatisation de la recherche
en nia pose un ensemble de questions sur
l'implantation géographique de ces
écosystèmes la protection de leur
invention et la diffusion ou non de leur
recherche l'origine des capitaux qui les
finan et
cetera on constate par ailleurs qu'on a
des centres de recherche y compris
Google par exemple je les cite parce que
voilà mais on a Microsoft également et y
compris les Chinois de Huawei qui ont
des centres de recherche plé en Europe
et en France qui produisent une
recherche pour Google Microsoft Huawei
ce qui pose aussi la question à qui
bénéficie cette recherche alors ce n'est
pas pour autant la fin de la recherche
publique ni de l'Open science ou ou
Scien ouvertes
euh on voit d'une part que on a cette
exigence de transparence cette exigence
de compréhension de ce qui se passe dans
l'intelligence artificielle qui
encourage cette ouverture ça c'est une
exigence du public et aussi des des des
décideurs public pour pouvoir développer
de bonnes lois il faut comprendre ce
qu'on essaie de légiférer euh donc pour
la transparence et l'ouverture sont un
outil pour développer une IA de
confiance et aussi pour diffuser la
connaissance et la rendre accessible là
on a parlé énormément de la France de
l'Europe des États-Unis je parler un
petit peu de la Chine mais cuid des pays
du Sud et des zones moins développées
qui ont encore moins accès à toutes ces
connaissance alors on voit que cet
objectif de science ouverte est reflété
par Bloom qui est a été financé par la
recherche publique française ainsi que s
kit learn qui est en open source je
reviendrai sur l'OP source tout à
l'heure mais on voit aussi que le Q Tha
donc cette initiative privée qui a un
statut de fondation et se situe dans une
démarche d'Open science donc c'est
quelque chose que je pense de très
positif il y a un lien open science Open
Source en tout cas dans certains types
certains aspects qui sont qui sont
communs et on voit que même des grandes
entreprises américaines comme ma par
exemple mettent à disposition leur
modèle comme le le lama 1 en tout cas la
première version qui était à disposition
uniquement des chercheurs et le Lama 2
qui maintenant est en open source euh et
ces ouvertures cette ouverture présente
des opportunités pour les écosystèmes en
développement et je considère que les
écosystèmes français et européens sont
des écosystèmes en développement dans
l'a par rapport à des écosystèmes déjà
très implantés comme l'écosystème
américain et chinois alors pour revenir
à la question des infrastructures un peu
plus matérielles je j'ai pas du tout
regardé à l'heure à laquelle j'ai
commencé bon euh attention je je vais
quand même essayer de me me contrôler
euh très bien alors donc je disais les
infrastructures qui permettent le
développement de l'ya puissance de
calcul les puces enfin plus
spécifiquement les processeurs GPU et et
le Cloud et CPU sur le la puissance de
calcul le HPC le high performance
computing ce sont des des capacités qui
initialement ça a été dit tout à l'heure
par Monsieur traapier sont détenus par
les gouvernements et les institutions
publiques notamment à des fins de
développement de recherche à des fins
militaires
mais aussi par les acteurs privés et les
plus grandes machines dans le secteur
privé sont détenus par NVIDIA IBM
Microsoft et Amazon on a aussi des
acteurs de l'énergie des hydrocarbures
et des Finances qui possèdent des gros
ordinateurs mais principalement les
acteurs du
numérique en Europe on a un programme
européen qui s'appelle l'entreprise
conjointe europc qui a été développée
depuis quelques années et qui vise une
mise en commun des capacités de calcul
en Europe à des fins de recherche ou
pour permettre à des entreprises
européennes d'utiliser ces ses capacités
de calcul euh pour euh pour développer
leur leur la recherche puis qu'elle peut
être scientifique mais aussi la
recherche en nia et on a désormais trois
super calculateurs européens dans le top
10 donc c'est pas mal parce que il y a
encore 2 ans on en avait euh un seul qui
était celui de ENI donc l'entreprise
d'hydrocarbures italienne donc on a un
progrès de ce point de vue-là et je
mentionnais Q l'initiative privée tout à
l'heure qui
s'appuiera sur scaleway et son super
calculateur qui sera a mis à disposition
notamment des startups et tout cela en
Open science donc on a quand même des
initiatives qui vont dans dans le bon
sens sur cet enjeu de la puissance de
calcul concernant les puces là où c'est
plus compliqué ça a été dit tout à
l'heure c'est que sur ce qui ce qui
relève des GPU des GPU c'est-à-dire les
cartes graphiques elles sont en en
situation de quasi monopole dans les
mains de Nvidia même si des d'autres
entreprises américaines telles que AMD
Intel ou Apple essaent de développer
leur propre GPU pour ne pas trop
dépendre d' Nvidia mais on voit que tout
le dépend de taiïwan pour la fabrication
des puces qui a des risques liés aux
chaînes d'approvisionnement des goulets
d'étranglement qu'on a vu après le le
covid notamment et aussi des enjeux de
restriction au transfert de technologie
notamment mené par les États-Unis côté
européen on a eu le lancement de
l'entreprise cperl qui développe un
microprocesseur pour le HPC le HPC
européen mais c'est c'est une CPU donc
c'est pas exactement les mêmes
processeurs qui sont utilisés pour
l'entraînement de de l'IA donc c'est
fait en coopération avec avec NVIDIA
donc là sur la question des puces on
reste quand même dans une situation très
contrainte en terme de dépendance la
question du cloud ça a été quasiment pas
abordé aujourd'hui alors que c'est
fondamental puisque tout je parlais des
super calculateurs avec les cartes
graphiques qu'on utilise pour développer
l'AR en fait tout ça c'est sur le Cloud
c'est-à-dire que personne dans les
grandes entreprises sauf les les
immenses entreprises que je mentionnais
tout à l'heure les IBM Microsoft et
cetera personne ne possède son propre
super calculateur donc on utilise le
Cloud pour accéder à la puissance de
calcul or euh les mêmes entreprises
américaines qui développent le logiciel
qui développe aussi pour certaines leurs
propres puces ont aussi le service de
cloud et ont tout intégré cette fameuse
intégration verticale que nous on n pas
en Europe et c'est sans doute une des
principales différences c'est qu'on a
pas d'acteur qui soit à tous les niveaux
de la chaîne de valeur et je mentionne
même pas le fait que ces mêmes
entreprises possèdent des satellites et
des câbles sous-marins voilà donc elles
ont aussi compris l'infrastructure de de
communication si vous voulez qui assure
que il y a une circulation très rapide
des données euh mais euh donc ce qu'on a
c'est une une dépendance structurelle y
compris des start-ups françaises ou
européennes qui veulent développer leur
IA parce qu'elles vont aller sur du
cloud Amazon Web Service ou sur du cloud
Microsoft Azure ou Google cloud qui vont
leur fournir tout un ensemble de suites
de de pil une pile technologique qui en
fait avec des packages très avantageux
sur le plan financier et en plus des
interfaces qui sont très user
friendendly et en fait à partir de là
vous avez une dépendance un peu
structurelle à certaine technologie qui
va se créer d'une part et d'autre part
vous avez aussi des enjeux de protection
des données parce que quand même ces
clouds américains bon ne sont pas
régulés par les mêmes règles que les
secnum Cloud et autres cloud souverain
qui sont en cours de on va dire de de de
construction ou de certification en
France
euh alors on a la croissance d'acteurs
français on a ici scaleway dans la salle
il y a également évidemment OVH 3DS
enfin le l'out scale de de ce système
euh donc ce qu'il faut c'est
effectivement parvenir à intégrer les
piles la puissance de calcul le Cloud et
la pile logiciel bien pratique et donc
on voit je reviens à cet exemple de Q
thaai là qu'il y a une une une dimension
de partenariat qui est assez
intéressante et qui qui offre
effectivement des opportunités à défaut
d'avoir une entreprise qui intègre
toutes ces différentes composantes du du
développement de de l'IA donc là aussi
on est plutôt dans la dans la bonne voie
même si c'est très très lent et qu'on a
pour le coup je pense voilà c'est c'est
enfin je dirais pas que la bataille est
perdue parce que après j reviendrai pour
dans ma conclusion c'est aussi une
question de préférence et de priorité
qu'est-ce qu'on va prioriser quand on va
développer son IA est-ce qu'on va
prioriser l'accès le plus rapide au
meilleur service où est-ce qu'on va
prioriser la protection de ses propres
données y compris de sa propriété
intellectuelle potentiellement un point
sur l'Open Source euh j'imagine qu'il
doit me rester quoi 5 minutes même pas
euh l'OP source c'est quand même une
opportunité pour les les les challengers
euh c'est l'Open Source assez méconnu en
réalité moi j'ai écrit un rapport
là-dessus il y a un an je me suis ah oui
Open Source intéressant et là j'ai
découvert voilà la la vastitude du sujet
90 % et plus des logiciels comprennent
des composants Open Source c'estd qu'il
est absolument partout et que les
grandes entreprises notamment certaines
entreprises américaines ont bien compris
l'intérêt d'utiliser l'open source et
les entreprises chinoises également je
vais je vais je vais je vais développer
ça dans un instant on est dans une
situation de très forte interdépendance
globale dans l'Open Source euh avec
notamment une forte par exemple
contribution chinoises c'est assez
intéressant de noter que les
contributions chinoises dans les
logiciels Open Source donc de code
ouvert accessi à tous sur des
plateformes comme GitHub plateforme de
dépôt de code euh une forte augmentation
de la présence chinoise depuis les
années 2010 et particulièrement depuis
2020 avec pour vous donner un un ordre
de grandeur au cours des années 2010
entre 2002 12 et 2018 le nombre de
membres chinois de la fondition
Fondation Linux Linux qui développe le
le système qui est en fait à la base de
l'infrastructure internet de du Cloud et
cetera enfin c'est vraiment un logiciel
d'infrastructure incontournable c'est
pas vraiment un logiciel c'est un
système d'exploitation bref la présence
chinoise dans cette fondation a augmenté
de 400 % en quelques années et on voit
que sur gththub donc la plateforme de
dépôt de code que j'évoqué tout à
l'heure les entreprises chinoises
Alibaba Huawei et ten cent sont dans le
top 20 des contributeurs au dépôt de
code que Huawei est le premier
contributeur au au noyau de Linux et que
baidou qui développe des logiciels pour
la conduite autonome collabore avec BMW
Volkswagen et cetera pour construire une
une alternative open source à la
conduite autonome qui est pour l'instant
dominée par par Tesla donc on a C cette
forte présence chinoise un écosystème
complètement mondialisé dans l'Open
Source qui est assez intéressant quand
on la confronte ça avec l'idée qu'on se
fait de la géopolitique actuellement
dans la technologie
euh l'Europe dans ce secteur contribue
seulement pour un/ers des contributions
sur sur GitHub selon les les estimation
et il y a seulement deux entreprises
dans le top 20 des contributeurs qui
sont deux entreprises allemandes SAP et
une autre sus et la France est
notoirement absente euh alors pourquoi
contribuer à l'Open Source question de
d'accessibilité au code qui qui qui est
disponible qui accélère le développement
logiciel qui permet aussi de créer des
logiciels qui sont interopérables entre
eux ça permet d'accéder au meilleurs tal
qui vont contribuer au code Open Source
ça permet de contrib de développer des
codes qui sont transparents enfin en
tout cas qui peuvent être évalués par
par les par les autres et ça crée aussi
ça permet de s'autonomiser en fait d'une
certaine manière de certaines
technologies
dominantes et de de contribuer à une
vision de l'Internet qui est quand même
portée par l'Europe qui est celle d'un
Internet diversifié non monopolistique
et non
privatisé euh donc il y a un rôle clé
pour les entreprises de se saisir
peut-être de cette opportunité de l'OP
source alors qu'on voit qu'il y a quand
même un peu de frilosité selon les
études qui ont été faites sur le sujet
frilosité des des Européens de se
risquer en fait à à à recourir
principalement à l'Open Source alors
enfin un dernier point sur on a de des
progrès qui sont en cours je le disais
je pense que je souhaite qu'on ne soit
pas dans un discours défétiste et même
si on a des enjeux de d'échelle
clairement en terme de de on a deux
acteurs dominants quand même qui sont
les États-Unis et la Chine
potentiellement par la différenciation
il y a une possibilité d'être influent
et d'être attractif euh finalement quel
intérêt aujourd'hui de développer un
chat GPT bis ce serait peut-être pas
forcément là que se situerait la
plus-value la plus-value pourrait se
situer dans le développement d'une nia
avec des usages et des utilité positiv
pour la société y compris si elles sont
spécialisées dans les enjeux du
climat voilà de que que sais-je les
enjeux en lien avec la désinformation
enfin les vraies questions de société
qui nous intéressent tous qui nous
apporte tous mais même pour les les
usages généraux tels que liya générative
chatbot et cetera en fait même siil un
avantage au premier rentrant il y a
aussi une capacité d'innover de et de
disrupter entre guillemets le marché
dans le numérique on a bien vu que
TikTok a complètement supplanté
Instagram en a rien de temps alors que
les États-Unis ont les considéré comme
étant très bien installé dans le domaine
des réseaux sociaux et les chinois sont
arrivés avec un autre type d'algorithme
une autre proposition qui a complètement
changé la donne euh voilà l'intégration
vert ça je l'ai dit et finalement ça
c'est donc pour les acteurs privés
notamment il y a beaucoup de
responsabilités qui reposent sur eux et
enfin je voudrais dire juste un petit
mot positif sur la
régulation le débat régulation versus
innovation est son est très souvent
juste résumé à réguler ses mal parce que
ça contraint l'innovation ce qui est mal
sauf qu'on constate que contraindre
l'innovation c'est aussi ce qui permet
de faire plus d'innovation
paradoxalement on a plus de dépôt de
brevets on a une innovation qui est plus
pointue et avec peut-être une meilleure
longévité aussi et des usages plus
utiles pour la société quand on est
contraint et ça on le voit avec les
contraintes qui sont placées dans par
exemple sur l'automobile pour ce qui est
de la question du climat et sur les
transports en général sur le le climat
pourquoi est-ce que les mêmes règles qui
s'appliquent pour la protection de
l'environnement ne pourrait pas
s'appliquer pour la protection de
l'humanité face à lia ça permet quand
même potentiellement de contraindre
l'innovation dans le bon sens
voir voir de de enfin c'est en fait
intrinsèque à l'innovation la contrainte
voilà j'arrête là merci merci beaucoup
pour cette note
positive et et et et je dirais
finalement pour résumer si si je me
permets un résumé en quelques mots tout
n'est pas perdu donc c'est plutôt
positif poursivre donc nous allons
entendre Caroline Chopinot vous êtes
directrice générale de H France Ia
organisme de référence en France qui
participe à fédérer animer l'écosystème
Ia dans notre pays cette association un
but non lucratif à sur une veille
technologique féère et anime autour de
l'IA et accompagne l'adoption et la
montée en compétence des acteurs
économiques après des études en
informatique et en mathématique puis une
thèse en IA que vous avez soutenu en
2007 vous rejoignez une PME spécialisée
dans la conception des simulateurs
d'entraînement pour la défense et la
sécurité civile fonctionnant grâce à l'a
vous avez ensuite créé votre PROE
startup craft ai euh en 2014 que vous
quittez en 2020 pour rejoindre h France
il a les thèmes que vous allez nous
présenter concernent la prise de
conscience de la France sur l'importance
de l'IA mais aussi sur les
questionnements de mise en place d'un
écosystème de structuration et de
solution pour obtenir une alternative
française et européenne face aux outils
américains c'est bien dit ou merci merci
pour
l'invitation je vais rebondir juste pas
sur Alice mais sur les propos d' sur sur
les ACT et sur la réglementation parce
qu'on a beaucoup entendu dans la la
table ronde avant que réglementer
c'était contraint de l'innovation et je
veux quand même donner aussi ce petit
côté positif au au règlement enfin moi
je ça fait 20 ans que je suis dans
l'intelligence artificielle donc quand
on m'a dit on va réglementer
l'intelligence artificiel j'ai hurlé je
me suis dit mais c'est pas possible on
peut pas mettre une une réglementation
sur une technologie ça n'a pas de sens
mais le règlement il est sur les usage
qu'on en fait cette technologie et je
pense que c'est important d'avoir ça en
tête et ça peut pas être le Far West
l'utilisation des nouvelles technologies
donc il faut y mettre un cadre pour la
confiance les highac c'est un cadre de
confiance à l'usage de ce type de
technologie et après il faut être mesuré
sur les contraintes qu'on met sur les
entreprises pour se mettre en conformité
mais c'est bien d'avoir en tête le fait
qu'on ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi
avec ce type de technologie là sur la
prise de conscience on dit tout le temps
on est en retard alors moi je vais être
très bisous nours aujourd'hui quand même
des fois je vais m'énerver un peu mais
euh mais quand même enfin il faut qu'on
mesure ure un peu notre retard on dit on
est en retard par rapport aux Américains
par rapport aux Chinois est-ce qu'on a
envie de faire la même chose que les
Chinois franchement tout à l'heure on
disait la Chine elle avance bien parce
qu'elle a accès à toutes les données
elle fait du scoring social c'est génial
ça fait pas partie de nos valeurs donc
ne nous dit ne faut pas qu'on se dise
qu'on est en retard juste parce qu'on ne
fait pas la même chose que ces gros
concurrents je pense qu'on peut faire de
la de façon aussi moins brutass et plus
intelligente on a une particularité
aussi en France et en Europe c'est comme
disait Alice on a beaucoup beaucoup de
petits acteurs en intelligence
artificielle dont fait partie Carelle
avec voxist et et le l'idée bah du voel
par exemple ou du Francia c'est
d'arriver à mutualiser et fédérer tous
ces petits acteurs pour les rendre plus
forts parce que c'est en travaillant
ensemble qui vont réussir à grandir et
être des alternatives européennes aux
grands américains on n arrivera
peut-être jamais à avoir notre pur
player il qui sait tout faire même si on
couple scaleway avec voxy avec machin
peut-être que c'est pas ça qu'il faut
qu'on doit faire il faut aider ces
acteurs à travailler ensemble et à se
positionner en force face à la
concurrence sur la prise de conscience
j'y reviens parce que du coup je dérive
on n'est pas on n jamais été en retard
en France en intelligence artificielle
depuis 20 ans que j'y suis il faut se
rendre compte quand même que
l'intelligence artificielle ça fait ça
c'est un peu le yoyo c'est les vagues il
a les grandes tempêtes tout se passe
bien tout le monde est content puis il y
a tous les creux de vagues où on se dit
en fait ila ça ne marche pas euh on est
en a en France lancé en 2012 le plan Big
Data c'était pour moi à l'époque qui
m'occupa de l'innovation de cette
fameuse petite PME qui s'appelait masa
donc je montais tous les projets
européens et nationaux pour cette
entreprise là pour accélérer son
innovation il faut comprendre que cette
PME c'était 40 personnes qui ne
travaillaient que pour la défense
c'était là où il y avait tout l'argent
tous les financements possibles pour
avancer sur l'IA en 2008 quand j'ai
rejoint cette boîte là on a effacé
partout sur les sites web qu'on faisait
de l'intelligence artificielle c'était
mal en 2012 quand il y a eu les plans
Big Data soudainement c'est redevenu
intéressant le traitement de la donnée
donc on a commencé à reparler un petit
peu d'intelligence artificielle mais pas
forcément avec ce terme là c'était du
traitement de la donnée mais néanmoins
moi à l'époque c'était le moyen pour moi
d'aller chercher de l'argent pour
accélérer sur ces sujets d'intelligence
artificielle parce qu'il y avait des
plans de financement du traitement de la
lé donc on était pas en retard on était
déjà en train de travailler sur ces
sujet d' à là en
2017 j'avais monté ma start-up et on
avait été sollicité un collègue et moi
pour travailler sur la première
stratégie nationale y c'était Francea
c'était piloté entre autres par le
cabinet d'Axel le maire et on avait
sorti en mars 2017 ce premier cette
première stratégie moi j'avais travaillé
sur tout ce qui était transfert
technologique puisque c'était un des
premiers sujets d'importance pour
arriver à accélérer sur l'intelligence
artifici iici 2017 mars 2017 on était
pas en retard j'ai essayé de retrouver
la Chine ils avaient publié leur plan il
a il me semble en juillet 2017 c'est ce
que je retrouve et les États-Unis
c'était en octobre 2016 on était pas en
retard on était pile poil dedans c'était
génial par contre peut-être on est pas
assez rapide ok on a des plans alors à
l'époque c'était financer la recherche
favoriser le transfert technologie faire
de la France une terre d'accueil des
start-ups en nia vous allez voir je vous
fais un peu l'historique c'est sympa
porter la croissance d'acteurs
emblématique pour soutenir l'écosystème
m en place un cadre réglementaire
favorisant le partage des données
sensibiliser àya et anticiper la
transformation des mités et former les
talents à liya de
demain effectivement on avait des bonnes
intentions et peut-être qu'on n pas on n
pas été assez vite on n pas été assez
rapide pour mettre ça en place un an
plus tard sortait le rapport villan qui
se concentrait sur l'éthique la
formation et qui avait identifié des
secteurs prioritaire d'application la
santé la défense l'environnement je peux
vous dire qu'en santé ça a marché on
fait une car ie des startup françaises
on a
281 start-up référencé en santé c'est là
où il y en a le plus donc ça a marché on
a été très très fort mais on a plein de
petits acteurs qui sont très très forts
en santé sur des sujets hyper
spécifiques de li appliqué à la santé on
a bien fait notre travail on les a fait
grandir ce qu'on a mal fait en faisant
ça si je peux donner une petite critique
là-dessus c'est qu'on favorise les
startup qui sont hyper verticalisés
c'est un vrai problème sur le
financement des des start-ups en parce
qu'à la base lia c'est quand même
quelque chose de très technique et qui
est très
horizontal quand on fait des
technologies de reconnaissance vocale on
se dit pas forcément dans quoi on va les
appliquer et donc en favorisant trois
secteurs prioritaires la santé la
défense l'environnement on n' pas aidé
toutes les autres entreprise qui
auraient pu accélérer sur d'autres
secteurs et c'est pour ça qu'on en a
moins on a quand même eu beaucoup de
financement et on est on est ravi de ça
à l'échelle de la France c'était quand
même plutôt pas mal on peut pas se
comparer euh ce que pe investir Google
ma dans dans ces projets d'IA
euh on a quand même aujourd'hui j'y
reviens à l'impression d'être à la
traain pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui
tout s'accélère donc comme je disais en
20 ans dia c'était plutôt mou euh moi je
vois je travaillais donc en mates
c'était en 2003 4 moi je travaillais sur
une technologie qui s'appelle les
systèmes multi-agents peut-être vous en
avez entendu parler maintenant euh donc
les systèmes multiagence ça été créé en
1980 c'est très très vieux et
aujourd'hui si vous regardez un peu on
est en train de s'exciter sur les LM
distribués sur des agents c'est très
sympa il y a plein de choses super cool
mais on voit enfin quand même 40 ans
avant qu'on arrive à avoir quelque chose
qui qui va au niveau industriel donc on
a l'impression d'être à la traain parce
qu'on va pas assez vite en France on a
été assez précurseur par exemple sur ce
sujet multiagent personne n'a voulu
mettre un COPEC là-dedans c'était asbine
et puis moi on pas arrêté de me dire que
c'était complètement
débile pourquoi parce qu'on prend pas de
risque donc si on prend pas de risques
forcément on teste pas et on met pas de
l'argent partout où on pourrait prendre
un risque intéressant pour essayer de
d'aller plus vite euh c'est
particulièrement
important aujourd'hui parce
qu'effectivement ça va vite Alice l'a
dit 2017 les premières publications sur
liage générative hugging face en 2021
avait fait une énorme série B donc
huggingf c'est une plateforme Open
Source qui déploie les Transformers qui
sont utilisés dans les modèles qui
excitent tout le mondeour aujourd'hui
autour de l'
générative et et en
2022 donc moi j'ai vu apparaître au WE
Françis tout début 2022 deux petites
start-ups qui faisaient le Lage
générative appliqué sur le marketing et
sur la génération de prototype
industriel c'était hyper intéressant
prototype industriel cette petite
start-up elle a fait
faillite cette année il me semble et
l'autre est pas en très bonne passe non
plus début 2022 j'ai commencé à trouver
ça quand même hyper excitant ces sujets
diagénérative et puis j'ai essayé de
diffuser un peu bah il y a un truc qui
se passe et tout mais c'était trop tard
en fait parce qu'on a laissé passer le
cap et c'est en novembre 2022 qui est
donc sorti chat GPT et où là on s'est
dit bah en fait c'est intéressant
comment on fait pour passer les messages
sur il y a des techn qui sortent il y a
des start-up qui font des trucs hyper
chouettes sur des sujets innovants
comment on fait passer le message que
c'est à ce moment-là qu'il faut
accélérer et s'y intéresser parce que
c'est trop tard le message passe pas le
message passe quand les Américains ont
sorti un truc et ça c'est un vrai
problème
le aujourd'hui euh il faut aussi se dire
donc que l'AS se déploie partout et
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup d'as
générative et c'est l'autre point que je
voulais aussi euh mettre en évidence
c'est que là on est en train de se dire
lia c'est lia générative moi ça fait des
mois et des mois que je suis dans des
tables rondes où on me demande en quoi
il y a génér a changé le monde des
entreprises non il y a générative pour
le moment a changé la vie de personne
les gens ont fait mumus avec chat GPT il
y a peut-être 1 % des entreprises qui
ont déployé vraiment chat GPT dans les
entreprises pour de vrai pour en faire
quelque chose lia c'est partout et c'est
des technologies de prédiction de
détection dans des images dans du texte
il y a des choses hyper opérationnel qui
fonctionne très très bien et là on est
en train de mettre tout notre argent
dans une solution pour essayer de
rattraper notre retard par rapport aux
Américains alors qu'il y a d'autres
boîtes qui font autres choses qui
mériteraient aussi d'avoir des
financements et donc c'est le même
problème que se dire on on cible
certaines filières certains secteurs
certaines filières prioritaire là on est
en train de se dire on va fixer nos
financements sur une technologie bien
spécifique il me semble que c'est une
erreur et qu'on va encore se retrouver
en retard sur d'autres acteurs qui
développent peut-être des technologies
qui demain ou après-demain se seront
hyper intéressantes pour nos
entreprises j'ai encore du temps ok je
pensais que j'allais pas avoir grand
chose à dire en fait je suis hyper
inspirée le alors il y a donc revenons
sur les problématiques de transfert
technologiqu parce que Alice l'a évoqué
puis on en a déjà parlé dans des
précédentes TBL rondes enfin c'est un
peu spoiler les questions de la Table
Ronde d'avant quand
même on a donc je parlais là de ces 40
ans sur les systèm multiagent mais bon
peut-être que demain on se rendre encore
compte que les SMA ça sert à rien donc
je dis ça c'est juste pour la euh on a
on a vrai en jeu à essayer de trouver
des solutions pour que la recherche
académique puisse passer dans les
entreprise et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
n'a pas trouvé la bonne solution on a
mis en place les trisia on a mis en
place des IRT on a mis en place des sats
il y a énormément d'acteurs qui sont en
train de travailler sur ces transferts
technologiques mais aujourd'hui ça n'a
pas résolu le problème les gros acteurs
arrivent à s'emparer de ce qui se fait
dans la recherche les petits ont du mal
les petits vont beaucoup s'appuyer on en
a parlé sur le crédit d'impôt recherche
je vois beaucoup beaucoup de start-ups
qui ont du mal à obtenir leur crédit
d'impôt recherche c'est la dernière en
date c'était il y a 15 jours 400000 €
prévu de crédit à impimport recherche
ils en ont que 100000 parce que quand
c'est évalué on considère que c'est pas
de la recherche mais c'est extrêmement
compliqué pour une petite start-up de
monter son dossier de CIR il faut être
accompagné il faut avoir des cabinets en
innovation il faut ça coûte énormément
pour faire un bon dossier de C et comme
disait William tout à l'heure ça
s'arrête à de la recherche qui est
évalué de façon très fondamentale en
fait est-ce qu'on a bien fait notre état
est-ce qu'on est bien positionné par
rapport à la recherche scientifique mais
du point de vue de l'entreprise sa
recherche sa R pour elle c'est hyper
disruptif et je pense que ce que fait un
Google c'est être disruptif dans dans
les usages de ces technologies et son et
de pas se mettre de limite nous on dit
aux entreprises si ta recherche elle est
pas meilleure que l'état de l'art
scientifique elle est pas intéressante
et c'est pas du c'est pas du C alors
c'est peut-être du C2i mais ça rapporte
moins donc c'est toujours moins
intéressant donc a essayer de favoriser
et et donner plus de de de possibilités
aux entreprises de s'appuyer sur ce
crédit d'impôt recherche qui est
vraiment formidable mais qui pose quand
même des contraintes pour pour justifier
qu'on fait bien de la recherche ça
pourrait être aussi une solution assez
intéressante et et je vais rejoindre ce
que disait Alice je suis désolé mais ce
matin j'étais en soutenance de thèse et
donc c'était une thèse je voulais vous
donner le titre parce que c'était très
drôle c'était enfin très drôle parce que
les sujets de test sont toujours très
drôles on comprend jamais rien c'est
l'application de la phylogénèse pour
l'optimisation des des modèles
d'apprentissage profond euh donc c'est
la neuroévolution appliqué à des modèles
de Deep learning et et la thèse était
vraiment super intéressante alors c'est
quelqu'un qui est proche de la retraite
qui soutenait sa thèse il a passé toute
sa vie dans une entreprise à essayer de
développer ça et de se faire financer ça
il a jamais réussi euh donc sa boîte on
peut dire que bah il a rien vendu sa
technologie d'un point de vue académique
est hyper intéressant c'est hyper
innovant il a jamais trouvé les moyens
de se faire financer ça donc tristesse
mais il soutient sa thèse il est content
il a l'impression d'avoir achevé quand
même ces 30 ans de à essayer de de
monter quelque chose sur ces sujets là
et puis il y a le président du du jury
qui a une remarque qui raisonne très
très bien avec les propos d'Alice il a
dit la recherche fondamentale est en
retard par rapport à la recherche privée
est-ce que ça vaut le coup encore de
faire de la recherche en IA dans le
monde académique alors là j'étais un peu
triste si le président du jury dit ça
c'est un peu perdu pour nous oui il y
avait encore du il y a encore du sens à
faire de la recherche fondamentale et de
la recherche sur l'A mais il y a du sens
aussi à aider les entreprises à faire
leur propres recherche et à exploiter ce
qui se fait en recherche fondamentale
pour faire de la recherche plus
appliquée et de soutenir ces initiatives
d'innovation de phillogenèse ou d'autres
pour l'optimisation des réseaux de
neurones mais tout ça pour se dire que
le transfert technologique est quelque
chose d'extrêmement important j'ai 50
pages mais j'ai pas fini mais j'ai plus
le temps c'est ça parce que je vous vois
lever la main une minute euh alors le la
cette dernière minute là je vais la
passer pour dire je il n'y a pas que le
public qui doit financer les entreprises
j'insiste et Carel l'a évoquer les
grosses entreprises en France et en
Europe et William l'a dit ont du mal à
acheter les délais d'achat parce que si
on parle pas juste de mettre de l'argent
on parle d'acheter une start-up son
business c'est de vendre sa technologie
les grosses entreprises ne savent pas
acheter de la technologie sauf à
Microsoft elles ne savent acheter que du
service ce qui favorise les grosses ESN
les grosses ESN travaillent avec qui
Microsoft je caricature un peu du coup
toutes nos start-ups ne se font pas
acheter par les grandes entreprises
acheter au sens technologique il faut je
ne sais pas comment mais il faudrait
pousser ces entreprises à acheter
européens acheter français à prendre le
risque oui peut-être que la start-up
demain elle va couler mais c'est trop
facile de s'appuyer toujours sur
Microsoft pour lancer ses projets d'IA
on a 280 start-up Ia en France qui sont
efficaces dont probablement 20 % vont
mettre la clé sous la porte à la fin de
l'année je dis 20 % parce que c'est nos
tau de ch au WE franciacia c'est
start-up qui ne repayent plus leur
cotise parce qu'elles n'ont plus
d'argent chaque année et et il faut
forcer je ne sais pas comment ces
grosses structures à prendre le risque
d'acheter français à DT n de start-up
françaises et européennes
merci merci à
vous donc en conclusion un
cocoico mais comment faire passer le
message merci donc je vais passer la
parole à Antoine Blondo vous êtes
condateur et Managing Partner d'Alpha
intelligence capital qui est un fond
dédié au technologie de rupture dont lia
vous êtes aussi à la tête d'AQ une
structure qui associe l'investissement
de conseil et l'incubation diplômé de SP
l'université japonaise de CuO Antoine
blodeau a occupé pendant plus de 20 ans
des fonctions stratégiques dans
différentes entreprises de la tech je je
laisserai n nous dire plus de détails
s'il le souhaite euh évidemment euh en
parallèle vous avez fondé plusieurs
entreprises spécialisées dans l' vous
allez évoquer à vos nombreuses
expériences internationales ainsi que
les enseignements que vous avez retirés
de de ces expériences
sur les raisons des succès ou des échecs
des uns et des autres notamment les
États-Unis et l'Asie et peut-être pour
dresser quelques recommandations pour
favoriser le succès du secteur en France
et en Europe
oui merci Patrick merci
BR
alors merci de m'avoir invité pour ce
qui est à mon avis très utile très
important alors je suis parti de France
34 ans
et j'ai fait toute ma carrière à
l'étranger ce que j'ai fait à l'étranger
y compris créer trois startup di dont ce
qui est devenu C qui appartient à Apple
maintenant n'aurait pas été possible ici
et c'est dommage parce que pas ce n'est
pas non solvable on peut on peut
résoudre ça le constat que je fais c'est
aujourd'hui très difficile et ça ne
s'arrange pas donc pour moi ce débat il
est important parce que il faut que ça
s'arrange c'est critique pourquoi parce
que le train a quitté la station euh il
y aura plus de Winter c'est fini euh lia
c'est le jour c'est le sujet du jour
mais c'est le sujet dans 10 ans dans 50
ans dans 100 ans pourquoi parce que tout
produit toute décision tout process
euh aujourd'hui cette assemblée notre la
langue que nous parlons est le fruit de
l'intelligence humaine et du moment où
on commence à augmenter cette
intelligence à la transformer à
transformer à la remplacer par de
l'intelligence machine tout produit
toute décision tout process toute langue
devient également une problématique
machine et donc le sujet le sujet de Lia
c'est pas le sujet du moment c'est le
sujet des 100 ans à venir et et et et
plus long encore alors
euh je vais parler tout à l'heure de des
États-Unis où j'ai passé beaucoup de
temps de la Chine où j'ai passé beaucoup
de temps de Israël je passe beaucoup de
temps un peu moins en ce moment
euh euh mais avant de parler de de ces
pays euh je et maintenant je suis
investisseur donc j'ai je suis inveseur
global mon mon fond investi aux
États-Unis en Europe en Israël et euh et
en Asie donc j'ai j'ai la chance d'avoir
une vue globale et dans l'IA uniquement
on investit dans l'IA profond
euh je vais parler de ça dans quelques
minutes mais avant je vais rebondir sur
quelques sujets importants qui ont été
développés euh auparavant le premier euh
dont je ve parler c'est tout ceci toute
cette la révolution de générative infin
elle apparaît comme planifié or en fait
c'est un énorme
accident alors nous sommes invur dans
Open
et open a open sourc fait un open source
de GPT
one il y a 4 ans 5 ans et gpt2 il y a 3
ans
il ne savaiit pas il ne savaiit pas
eux-mêmes que en continuant à augmenter
la puissance de calcul et a augmenté le
nombre de données et la taille des
raéseaux
neuronaux qui étit mis en place il ne
savait pas qu'ils allaient arriver à ce
que à gpt3 et chat
GPT j'ai vu un an avant le la release de
chat GPT j'ai vu une entreprise
américaine qui avait une solution
quasiment comparable qui était adossée
au GPT de chat GPT donc à la au au large
language model de de open a mais qui
n'avait et qui avait l'interface qui
avait créé la prère la première
interface
conversationnelle que open n'avait pas à
l'époque j'ai vu ça céit appliqué au
jeux vidéo et je me suis dit mais ça
c'est la science-fiction c'est ce que
j'ai essayé de créer il y a 20 ans lors
lorsqu'on a travaillé avec la DARPA pour
pour essayer de créer sire comment vous
faites
et ils m'ont expliqué au P il ne savait
pas d'accord donc c'est un accident et
c'est important de savoir parce que
comme c'est un accident Google très bon
exemple Google a été surpris Google
Google a été surpris par la sortie de
chpt comment cela est possible c'est un
accident c'est pas planifié donc ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que l'industrie
découvre ce qui se passe l'industrie
n'est pas tout à fait sûre de ce qui a
été inventé et d'ailleurs lorsque vous
regardez le discours
parmi les plus grands scientifiques y
lein qui est au bord de notre fond et
donc deux des quatre paires des rés
neuronaux de Deep learning deep learning
r neuronaux profonds qui disent tous les
deux que ce sont des plutôt des machines
stupides qui qui simulent ou imite le
langage humain et qui ne crée pas de
modèle de connaissance véritable vous
avez une frange d'industrie qui pense
comme ça puis une autre frange Jeff
finton euh
ou Yoshua benio qui sont du même niveau
qui ont tous les trois sur les quatre
ont gagné le le même prix le le Turing
Price qui est le Nobel price de l'i qui
disent bah non au contraire on pense que
ces réseaux neuronaux Transformers sans
doute lorsqueil ils il ils traitent
autant de données et qu'ils ont un
paramétrage qui est si large sans doute
ils développent une
une connaissance implicite il
développent leur propre modèle du monde
qui n'est pas explicite mais qui existe
et qui est véritable donc c'est une
nouvelle forme d'apprentissage on ne
sait pas aujourd'hui c'est un débat
quasi
philosophique ce ça veut dire quoi aussi
ça veut dire qu'on est tout au début et
que ça va continuer à augmenter que
cette cette rapidité
d'innovation va continuer à
à à augmenter et que dans 10 ans dans 20
ans dans 30 ans on aura des choses qui
sont complètement impensables
aujourd'hui y compris en terme
scientifique première chose et donc faut
pas faut pardonner à l'industrie le fait
que ben c'est une cacophonie un
brouillard et que ben nous on apprend en
même temps que le reste du monde
première
chose je voudrais parler de la boîte
noire j'ai beaucoup de sujets mais je
vis pas la boîte noire parce
que beaucoup de il y a une une des
grandes inquiétudes j'ai entendu le mot
inquiétude souvent aujourd'hui et une
des inquiétudes c'est liée à ça la boîte
noire j'en ai parlé à à Bruno lorsqu'on
s'est vu récemment euh euh qu'est-ce qui
est une plus une plus boîte une plus
noire boîte si je puis dire que la boîte
noire de la c'est le cerveau humain le
cerveau humain est beaucoup plus noir
que l'a or euh on on le traite euh on a
réussi sur des siècles et des
millénaires à gérer ce cerveau humain
comment on le fait on le fait avec des
lois avec des habitudes des
convenances on sait le gérer tous les
jours on donne à des millions d'humains
des armes ça s'appelle les
voitures on fait confiance à des humains
en leur donnant des des véhicules qui
vont très vite qui peuvent tuer très
facilement et pourtant on leur fait
confiance comment on fait ça on a un
code de la route on a permis de conduire
on a une
nomenclature euh on a des lois et bien
on peut faire la même chose pour l'ire
c'est très difficile pour parler du
problème régulatoire de réguler lia je
pense que l' Act est très le titre est
mauvais déjà pour commencer je vais pas
parler du contenu parce que ça serait
sans doute péjoratif mais euh euh je
pense que l' Act comme comme titre est
très mauvais on ne régule pas
l'intelligence humaine on la régule dans
son
application de même on on doit réguler
l'IA dans son application aux
États-Unis j'ai investi par exemple dans
une entreprise qui fait de la
radiologie médical également de la
pathologie donc du l'analyse de de l'âme
de biopsie
euh ces sociétés font une application
auprès de la de la FDA pour réguler leur
système donc c'est pas on régule pas li
a la technologie on régule son
application en l'occurrence dans la
santé donc voilà quelques
quelques réflexions
sur sur pourquoi peut-être il faut
dédramatiser et avoir un discours plus
positif parce que sans discours positif
il n'y aura pas de Momentum et sans
momentum l'Europe ne ne sera o là elle
doit être alors je vais parler de
pourquoi pourquoi j'ai j'ai moi
euh surtout comme beaucoup de Français
mais pas seulement de français des
Indiens des Russes des Anglais des
Allemands
euh travailler décid de travailler aux
états-unis plutôt qu'en Europe alors les
raisons sont multiples et et en fait le
le l'objectif c'est quel est le retour
sur l'investissement en temps en énergie
qu'on va avoir c'est pas seulement un
retour financier c'est c'est un retour
d'impact c'est et et quand vous parlez
un ingénieur dans la salicon vallé bien
sûr il fait de l'argent bien sûr il
gagne son il gagne son argent et parfois
il ne le gagne pas parce que sa startup
disparaît mais quand vous parlez à iné
Silicon Valley son objectif numéro 1
toujours c'est l'impact toujours
alors pourquoi les États-Unis
aujourd'hui sont
devant d'abord la première raison elle
est claire c'est je viens d'en parler
c'est les ressources donc le les
cerveaux
aujourd'hui 60%
des des développeurs et et des
chercheurs de poes dans le monde dans
l'IA travaille soit en université soit
pour les entreprises américaines 60 % ce
qui est intéressant j'aiis j'avais le
chiffre quelque part ici c'est que
beaucoup beaucoup d'entre eux sont ne
sont pas américains plus de 2 tiers sont
étrangers et donc ça veut dire plus de
de tiers en fait ont fait leur undergrad
donc leur premier
cycle à l'étranger pas aux États-Unis ok
après ils sont venus aux États-Unis
et et chiffre intéressant sur ces 2
tiers de d'étrangers 29 % sont chinois
donc a un transfert de cerveau de la
Chine vers les États-Unis
56 % des Chinois qui vont faire leurs
Masters leur PhD aux
États-Unis 56 %
reste donc il y a une très important ça
et quand on parle de l'éducation en
France et on parle des Français mais non
n parlons pas des Français parlons des
gens qui sont
ici moi je voudrais que les Indiens les
Nigériens les les Algériens les
Tunisiens les
Ukrainiens viennent ici et profitent de
notre qualité d'enseignement
scientifique dans le dans le second dans
le dans le
tertiaire alors ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est
l'investissement euh j'ai j'ai regardé
en pour pour avant avant de venir ici
j'ai regardé les chiffres entre 2013 et
2022 il y a eu 250 milliards de dollars
investis par les investisseurs privés he
privés aux États-Unis dans le domaine de
l'IA 250 milliards c'est la Chine c'est
95 l'Angleterre c'est je crois
euh
18 Israël 11 la France un peu moins de 7
entre 2012 et 2013 2022 d'accord en 2022
l'année dernière le le le l'écart C à
crru les États-Unis ont ont investi 47
milliards euh dans l'IA euh la France à
peu près 2 c'est un ratio de 1 à 25 en
gros c'est incroyable euh alors pourquoi
euh pourquoi parce que c'est pas
seulement parce que les gens ont de
l'argent parce que l'argent il existe un
peu partout et franchement il y a je
connais beaucoup d'investisseurs
américains et nous-même d'ailleurs on
est prêt à investir en France dire je
l'ai fait mais et les Américains
investissent en France ils aiment bien
préconçu qu'ils investissent pas en
France c'est pas le cas ils aiment bien
investir en France et ils reconnaissent
que il y a il y a un vivier de chercheur
et un tissu économique dans l' qui est
fort ici sur le en principe en tout cas
mais pourquoi ça ne vient pas parce que
en fait les investisseurs américains ENF
de manière générale les investisseurs
investissent là où il ils savent que le
risque va être récompensé d'accord moi
je suis un capital risqueur maintenant
j'étais entrepreneur pendant 15 ans
maintenant j'investis j'investis et je
veux que lorsque j'investisse je fasse
de je veux faire de l'argent par
définition donc je veux que
l'environnement dans lequel j'investis
apprécie la prise de risque alors ça
commence par l'entrepreneur mais ça
continue par le gouvernement par les
entreprises ça a été dit et c'est très
important qui sont les early adopters
les gens qui adoptent les technologies
en amont dans le monde aujourd'hui c'est
qui c'est pas malheureusement les
entreprises européennes ce sont les
entreprises américaines les grandes les
petites les moyennes pourquoi parce
qu'elles sont environnement
concurrentiel tel qu'elles sont obligées
d'investir lourdement dans ce domaine
donc une autre recommandation c'est
clair c'est
essayer je vais répéter ce que vous avez
dit très bien de de de construire des
passerel entre le monde de l'entreprise
établi et le monde des start-ups
euh pour créer ce qu'on appelle en
anglais un pool effect une traction
commerciale qui vient de euh du client
euh alors et et puis on oublie toujours
parce qu'on on parle de Google on parle
de ma on parle de Nvidia mais pour pour
chaque Google il y a combien de milliers
de start-ups qui ont échoué aux
États-Unis des milliers et et cette
destruction créatrice c'est c'est le le
terme creative destruction c'est le
terme qui est qui est qui est utilisé à
San Francisco
elle est en fait c'est quoi c'est une
prime à l'essai c'est une prime à
l'échec hein on on on on essaie ça
marche pas on recommence ça marche pas
on recommence ça marche parce que c'est
ce n'est qu'en faisant qu'on apprend à
réussir donc la prime l' échec ça ça
paraît un peu bizarre mais c'est le cas
euh et puis la dernière chose que je
voudrais évoquer c'est le le
coût régulatoire et alors j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure de de de à mon avis ce
qu'il faut réguler et ce qu'il ne faut
pas
réguler il y
a aux États-Unis de manière générale une
une on innve d'abord on régule après
d'accord alors il y a des avantages des
inconvénients mais l'avantage l'avantage
c'est que quand quand on on commence on
sait au bout d'un certain moment ce
qu'il faut réguler parce qu'on voit les
problèmes donc c'est assez empirique
comme méthode
et et ça marche de temps en temps pas
toujours hein ça marche mais de manière
générale je trouve que ce système où on
essae d'abord
et et il va y avoir un peu de dégâts oui
mais on l'accepte comme société pourquoi
parce que le corelire de ceci et ben
c'est Infiné euh une croissance
supérieure un niveau de vie supérieur et
puis on l'espère une une compétitivité
supérieure qui fait que bah Infiné on
est dans on est
leader mondial dans le domaine donc
voilà donc je voulais parler des
États-Unis je pourrais parler de la
Chine également mais peut-être que j'ai
pas le temps vous vous me direz Patrick
minutes alors je je vais pas parler de
la Chine je vais parler à la place de
Israël et de l'Angleterre parce que ce
sont deux modèles intéressants parce que
je pense que bon la France et la France
à la France on a la taille qu'on a
et et peut-être que ce n'est pas la
meilleure idée d'essayer de concurrencer
les Américains sur leur terrain mais il
y a deux exemples qui sont assez proches
de nous qui marchent bien Londres est
une la plus grande plateforme européenne
dans
l'IA TelAviv il y il y a 630 start-up d'
à téaviv 630 euh
alors pourquoi il y a une des raisons
pour lesquell C ces deux pays
sont marchent bien dans le domaine de
l'a c'est que
elle ces pays ne considèrent pas le leur
marché domestique comme leur
marché une entreprise israélienne une
start-up israélienne typiquement j'en ai
investi dans j'ai investi dans plusieurs
et bicéphale ou plutôt bicontinent elle
a une équipe en Israël une équipe aux
États-Unis et le marché américain et
leur marché
domestique les Anglais c'est pareil ils
sont beaucoup plus intégrés au marché
américain donc il a une exigence
d'excellence il y a une taille de marché
qui est importante qu'ils adressent tout
de
suite alors que nous Français ou nous
allemands c'est pareil pour en Allemagne
le premier réflexe c'est le marché local
et le marché et le marché qui nous
intéresse alors que ça devrait pas être
le cas si on veut être vraiment
ambitieux il faut il faut il faut voir
que le monde de World le monde est notre
marché et c'est ça qu'on doit viser
sinon on ne créera pas alors on n pas
besoin de créer le prochain Google
peut-être c'est compliqué mais pourquoi
pas on y arrivera peut-être mais créer
le prochain leader sur un vertical donné
le prochain
sforce.com et cetera voilà donc quelques
réflexions j'espère que c'est utile
merci merci merci
beaucoup je crois que collectivement euh
à entendre vos propos on peut se
souhaiter un accident français donc dans
les prochaines années alors des des
questions j'imagine dans la
salle
hop merci merci beaucoup c'était
vraiment très stimulant en fait ah oui
je me présente moi je suis actuellement
en fin de doctorat en philosophie euh
sur l'éthique de l'intelligence artif
artificielle enfin plus précisément la
question d'explicabilité et d'équité à
l'ENS juste à côté et en même temps
voilà je suis pilote du groupe de
travail sur l'éthique du H Francia
Thomas souverin et j'aimerais justement
parce que on a eu une série de table
rondes qui ont été passionnante me
demander comment les articuler bon enfin
c'est une question ouverte évidemment
parce que on a parlé notamment de de
l'éthique avec vous Madame rgier et vous
avez exprimé que peut-être par rapport à
ce geste initiale de l' Act en tout cas
moi je l'avais vu comme ça qui est quand
même qui s'inscrivait dans une sorte de
filiation suite au groupe de d'experts
de haut niveau qui avaient été mandaté
par la Commission européenne donc en
2019 euh que voilà vous avez exprimé
votre disons votre réserve par rapport à
l'inclusion de ces mêmes principes dans
les textes donc j'aimerais savoir
justement par rapport à ce que vous vous
disiez aussi madame panier euh qu'est-ce
qu'on va prioriser justement nous
européens nous Français ou et l'éthique
et où est-ce qu'il est déjà dans le
texte aujourd'hui de l' Act pour pouvoir
en savoir plus et où est-ce qu'il peut
être et doit être concrètement en c'est
c'est des questions ouvertes mais
j'aimerais vous entendre
là-dessusy peut-être si vous voulez
ensuite élaborer mais je vourais juste
dire une chose moi je je suis pas
spécialiste de la réglementation à la
base donc je suis pas juriste et cetera
et on verra ce qui ressort des
discussions mais simplement ce que je
voudrais rappeler parce que ça a pas été
dit et on a toujours l'impression que le
AA Act ça va s'appliquer que aux
entreprises françaises et ça va
handicaper que les entreprises
françaises ou européennes mais en fait
ça va s'appliquer à toute entreprise qui
veut entrer sur le marché et fournir des
services en Europe et ça c'est quand
même une différence ça veut dire que ça
va avoir un un impact sur le
développement de l'IA en Chine aux
États-Unis et cet effet du marché
européen il est pas il est pas il est
pas àodin en terme d'influence normative
voilà même si peut-être que les entre
entreprises auront les moyens de se dire
bah pour le marché européen je développe
quand on est Google ou voilà peut-être
qu'ils vont développer certains certains
systèmes spécifiques mais moi je serait
pas surprise qu'il y ait des effets
ricochés et même le rgpd dont on a
entendu énormément de critiques
aujourd'hui et à bonne pour de bonnes
raisons sur le plan des contraintes pour
le développement de l'intelligence
artificielle même de contraintes pour
les usagers en terme de de
d'opérationnalisation du du règlement il
n'empêche que ça a quand même servi de
et ça continue à servir de modèle pour
des tas de pays pour développer leur
propre le leur propre règlement euh donc
la dimension vertueuse avec cette
influence extraterritoriale quand même
du règlement du règlement européen qui
sortira on l'espère bientôt et je ne
doute pas que un bon compromis sera
trouvé entre les enjeux éthiques et les
enjeux quand même de en terme économique
et de marché toutes les questions
d'équilibre juste juste un commentaire
là-dessus leè le problème et et que
Google Facebook peuvent se payer euh la
con
au règlement européen ils ont les
capacités de le faire donc pour
moi la surrégulation en fait al je dis
pas que c'est la surrégulation mais la
surrégulation est un avantage au aux
existants au grand grand et pour moi
elle contraint et c'est ça le plus grave
mon point de vue elle contraint le tissu
de startup
européens il va falloir y aller d'une
main tremblante
question en premier rang la main haute
ouais la main haute en Rous écoutant en
fait est-ce que surtout Antoine blond
est-ce que les les start-up en matière
d'IA et di sa si on les soutient sont
pas condamnés à aller chercher des
marchés aux États-Unis comme Israël et
comme Londres et donc inversement on se
condamne aussi les grands groupes
français et l'État dont tu parlais tout
à l'heure à travaillé uniquement avec
des Google qu'on a vu ce matin et des
Microsoft et les grand groupe français
pour se rassurer justement travaille
avec ces ces grandes sociétés qui elles
bon bah arrive à s'adapter aux
régulations européennes donc de toute
façon rgpdi acte ça condamne les
start-up françaises et européennes de
toute façon bon VO je pense qu'il faut
faire attention je pense que le le le
mot condamné est un peu
fort peut-être que le le le mot condamné
dans la pour la deuxième partie de de ce
que vous disiez juste maintenant est
peut-être le bon mot mais pour la
première partie si si je veux créer une
start-up à Paris à Berlin et et et mon
ambition est là comme entrepreneur bien
sûr je veux aller là où le marché va va
accepter ma solution or les Américains
les grandes entpr américaines sont tout
à fait prêtes à acheter européens ou
acheter chinois ou acheter où vous
voulez enfin un peu moins chinois
maintenant mais euh
elles vont elles tendent vers
l'excellence technologique et
l'excellence de produit après il faut
savoir vendre il faut savoir présenter à
l'américaine tout à l'heure William en
parlait c'est il faut savoir le faire
mais c'est pas euh c'est beaucoup moins
sorcier que de développer un produit euh
à base d'IA fondamental donc je pense
que le mot condamner c'est pour moi
c'est plutôt une opportunité voir le
marché américain comme marché un marché
d'opportunité très bien eu une question
encore devant et puis après oui une ici
on les prend les deux et puis ça ça les
dernièresou euh merci pour pour la
qualité de cette journée c'était
vraiment c'était vraiment
passionnant bon je suis consultante mais
je suis aussi élu local j'entends depuis
tout à l'heure et c'est à c'est en tant
que consultante que je suis invitée pas
en tant queélu local mais c'est c'est
c'est assez troublant j'entends depuis
tout à l'heure évoquer le le le marché
des
entreprises qui ne sont pas forcément en
Europe en France des early adopteur euh
en terme d'IA moi il y a il y a un autre
domaine d'activité qui est quand même
très très important dans lequel je ne
vois pas Dely adopteur voire même
beaucoup beaucoup de retard c'est celui
de la collectivité locale régionale et
cetera or il y a des gisements de
productivité dans ces domaineslà je
pense que pour sur tout ce qui est
maintenance logistique enfin tout ce qui
est prédictif et cetera il y a
énormément de choses à faire or
aujourd'hui et je m'adresse tout
particulièrement au sénateurs qui sont
dans cette salle euh tel que sont
organisés les collectivités locales les
interco ne prennent pas en main ces
sujets-là les collectivités ont pas
forcément les moyens ou estime ne pas
les avoir ou non'ont pas les compétences
et et et et je trouve ça extrêmement
dommage compte tenu euh de de de la
qualité des intervenants français dont
j'avoue je je j'avais pas pris
conscience avant de d'être là
aujourd'hui euh bonjour Je je vous
remercie déjà pour pareil pour la
qualité de de ce colloque euh j'ai
beaucoup d'informations et vraiment une
qualité d'information très précise
auquel je m'y attendais pas donc c'est
très agréable je voulais juste rebondir
sur la condamnation justement des
entreprises ou des start-ups françaises
avec l' Act ou le
rgpd faut savoir que sur sur le rgpd ça
a poussé quand même pas mal de solutions
françaises notamment avec le fait que il
y a eu des condamnations au niveau de
Google qui oblige toutes les entreprises
en tout cas où je fais partie de
l'Association Française de Cardiologie
en tant que Chargé de communication
digitale et on peut pas utiliser par
exemple Google Analytics et ça met
énormément en avant des des solutions
qui ont été développées en Europe et en
France comme matomo
eu et la deuxième chose c'est aussi je
pense que l' Act ben ça va forcément ça
va forcément réglementer beaucoup de
choses euh euh en France au niveau de
l'intelligence artificielle avec pas mal
de même au niveau de l'intelligence
artificielle
générative de solutions françaises qui
ont été développé et qui s'adapte à la
réglementation européenne et française
dans leur développement ce qui n'est pas
le cas forcément actuellement aux
États-Unis et on va se retrouver pareil
avec des solutions françaises qui vont
être déjà préparé à cette réglementation
vis-à-vis des solutions étrangères
voilà bien alors peut-être euh je va
vous demander de de de réagir rapidement
et peut peut-être en conclusion aussi de
cette table ronde je je me permettrai
moi de de d'avoir une réaction sur la la
question concernant les collectivités
locales puisqueen fait c'est un sujet
qui est quand même un sujet d'actualité
puisque le le knige euh à cette semaine
donc dans son conseil d'administration
euh pris euh donc la décision de
justement
piloter tout ce qui était données et
gestion de données euh pour les
collectivités locales donc je pense que
vous aurez des nouvelles bien bientôt
sur le sujet voilà et si je peux
rebondir sur ce sujet là vous avez un
super appel à projet mais je sais pas
s'il est clôturé euh pour les
collectivités bah l'appel à projet il a
pour les territoires qui est porté par
ecolam au ministère de la transition
écologique si vous n'avez pas entendu
parler de ce dispositif là il faut
vraiment le diffuser partout ils ont eu
neuf projets déposés à la au premier
batch là ils en étaient à une trentaine
si au prochain on peut faire x 3 x 4 ce
serait génial et l'idée du dispositif
c'est d'accompagner justement les
collectivités à mettre en place de Lia
de préférence de l'IA frugal sur les
sujets de la transition écologique ce
qui mon sens c'est un bon point de
départ et d'être accompagné par du coup
un consortium d'acteurs technologiques
qui a qui peuvent aider les collectivité
qui forcément n'ont pas les ressources
pour déployer ça tout seul donc c'est
une très bonne démarche de
financement ouais moi je je lance un
appel euh il y a quelque chose qui
serait très utile moi je viens de vender
donc on a connu en 2010 xintia 29 morts
euh il y a eu dans le Pas de Calais mais
aussi cette année euh dans d'autres
départements dans d'autres régions des
des inondations euh pour l'instant on a
eu soit des submersions marines ça
venait de la mer soit des inondations
qui venaient de la terre mais on n
jamais eu la rencontre fatale entre une
submersion marine euh et euh aussi une
pluviale d'ondation de rivière et cetera
vraiment si une boîte pouvait un jour
travailler sur la prédiction en fonction
des Maré en fonction parce que les
coefficients de Maré c'est important
pour les su sur Marine en fonction là
encore des pressions atmosphériques en
fonction là aussi de la pluvométrie
croyez-moi ce serait très intéressant je
suis même sûr que on pourra avoir des
assurances qui permettent de nous aider
aussi à financer ce genre de choses je
le dis comme ça he comme j'en profite
pour que ça tombe dans des oreilles
peut-être
averti merci vous voulez j'ai déjà
beaucoup parlé donc merci beaucoup pour
les commentaires derni question je vous
laisse conclure monsieur Blondo écoutez
c'est un honneur de le faire euh merci
euh moi j'ai un message relativement
simple eu qui est
euh il faut pratiquer pour
comprendre ce n'est qu'en pratiquant
qu'on comprend et une fois qu'on a
compris euh on peut créer les cadres euh
de de régulation les cadres de
développement
mais il faut le pratiquer et donc moi
j'ai un appel je dirais à l'action qui
est pour tout le monde qui est de ne pas
hésiter à se lancer dans la pratique
vous avez parlé des Collectiv
collectivité locale c'est tout à fait le
cas ne pas hésiter à aller dans la
pratique c'est pareil pour les
entreprises lorsque les grandes
entreprises viennent me voir et me
disent Antoine comment comment je dois
me lancer dans l' je leur dis mais
mettez en place un petit projet quelques
ingénieurs quelques chefs de produit
prenez un aspect de votre produit votre
service et essayez de de le de de de
enable voilà
et et c'est c'est en pratiquant qu'on
apprend l'information c'est le ner de la
guerre et lia c'est la guerre de demain
d'aujourd'hui et de demain merci
beaucoup je repasser la parole à notre
président merci Patrick voyez quand même
je sais pas quelle image vous avez du
Sénat mais on on a des d'excellent
spécialistes depuis ce matin qui ont
animé ces réunions Patrick suit toutes
les questions numériques il a plusieurs
responsabilités merci aux intervenants
on va passer euh puisque je pense que
Christian sylvie buoussoil est en ligne
il est président de la Commission de
l'industrie de la recherche de l'énergie
du Parlement européen c'est une des deux
commissions qui est impliquée dans la
construction de l'ct puisque à avec la
commission des libertés publiques il
parle heureusement beaucoup mieux le
français que je ne parle le roumain
monsieur le Président merci d'être avec
nous est-ce que vous m'entendez
oui je vous entends vous m'entendez oui
on vous entend très bien je vais vous
laisser la parole on vous allez conclure
une journée qui a été très intéressante
qui se déroule à partir du Sénat
français et consacré donc à
l'intelligence artificielle on s'est
posé la question de la réglementation il
y a bientôt l'ct qui arrive donc au
niveau européen il y a eu des comment
dirais-je l'expression d'un certain
nombre de d'inquiétudes ici notamment
sur la régulation parce que quand on est
en France quand on n aussi en Europe on
se dit que la régulation pourrait
étouffer un secteur qui est en train de
se déployer qui est tout juste naissant
donc il y a ces dialectique entre entre
la régulation et puis aussi l'innovation
et puis il y a aussi une autre approche
un intervenant à l'instant Antoine nous
disait que comme on on ne on ne régule
pas l'intelligence humaine on en régule
les applications est-ce que une
régulation totalement uniforme ou plutôt
une régulation qui s'attacherait
peut-être à définir un cadre certes mais
ensuite qui s'attacherait à différents
usages à différentes applications
pourrait être rejouable en tout cas
merci de nous donner ici et ce soir
votre vision qui sera importante puisque
dans le trilogue qui devra aboutir parce
que il y a bien sûr la la commission y
travaille mais ensuite ça ne pourra être
une législation européenne que si bah ça
c'est successful pour le pardon c'est
c'est réussi pour le le dans le trilogue
entre la Commission le Parlement bien
sûr et le Conseil les chefs d'État et de
gouvernement merci à vous en tout cas
d'avoir accepté de nous parler ce
soir merci beaucoup pour l'invitation et
je regrette que je pourrais pas être à
Paris
euh ni même à Bruxelles parce que je
suis à COP je suis aux émirates et
j'espère que la connexion va durer euh
donc encore une fois merci de m'avoir
invité aujourd'hui pas nécessairement
conclure une journée très intéressant
j'ai j'ai j'ai vu les dernières dizaines
de minutes des discussions des questions
très intéressantes des interventions
très intéressants mais plutôt
transmettre quelques dernièr remarquees
après vos discussions et vous donner
quelques euh informations sur les
discussion européenne vous avez raison
le trilogue euh n'a pas Bouti à faire
une conclusion
euh la nuit passée euh demain vendredi
il essaie de de de reprendre il y a
beaucoup de questions techniques mais
aussi il y a des questions de principe
entre le Conseil les représentant des
États membres et le Parlement avec le
soutien et avec l'assistance de la
Commission européenne mais je suis sûr
qu'une conclusion sera trouvée euh et je
peux vous vous dire encore une fois que
pour le Parlement européen pour le
comité industrie recherche et énergie
que je dirige c'était pas le comité en
charge de cette de cette dossier
législative mais nous avons donné une
opinion qui a été prise en compte c'est
une autre comité le comité de marché
intérieur qui s'occupait du rapport du
fond et qui euh aussi à mener les
négociations avec le le Conseil de
l'Union européenne mais pour nous pour
le Parlement pour les deux commissions
et pas seulement pour les deux
commissions la transformation numérique
est une des priorités clair nous avons
vu avec euh nous avons vu que la
Commission européenne actuelle pour la
Commission européenne actuelle aussi
était une priorité clé donc c'est c'est
une question que nous avons soutenu
beaucoup C dernière année la Commission
européenne inspirée et mobilisée par
Monsieur breton et nous travaillons très
bien avec Monsieur breton a déjà
présenté des communications et des
propositions
législatives à C à ce sujet le sujet
numérique et elle est demandé à en
présenter encore quelques-unes jusqu'à
la fin de son mandat nous avons
travaillé surtout en nitre sur le Data
sur le cybersécurité mais sur d'autres
dossiers qui tche la transition
numérique euh et bien sûr comme j'avais
déjà dit sur la intelligence
artificielle parce que la numérisation
et l'intelligence artificielle font déjà
partie de nos vies et vont changer nos
vies et je j'ai vu que nous sommes tous
conscients de ça et permettront de
trouver des solutions à bon nombre de
défis auxquels nous sommes confrontés
par exemple notre capacité à collecter
stocker traiter des données grâce aux
algoritthmes de l'intelligence
artificielle augmentera l'efficacité et
la productivité et renforcera la
compétitivité globale de notre Union
européenne aussi des autres avantages
des meilleurs soins de santé des
transport plus sûr et plus propres
encore une fois je suis à COP 28 et
c'est très important pour le futur
d'utiliser tous ces euh applications
numériques d'intelligence artificiel
pour aussi aboutir à nos objectif
stratégique du PACT vert et pour
implémenter l'accord de Paris aussi une
fabrication plus efficace une énergie
moins cher et plus durable avec
l'intelligence artificielle dans tous
les domaines comme les voyages
spatiauuxx les datas la santé ou
l'analyse du climat tout est connecté
mais vulnérable à la fois c'est pour ça
que nous sommes très concernés et je
vous ai dit déjà que notre comité a déjà
travaillé et on a aussi trouvé une
conclusion à quelques dossier
législativ qui concerne le cy
cybersécurité pour euh bien sûr avoir
des solutions à cyberattaque euh qui
sont beaucoup plus nombreux après euh
après les dernières années après le
covid la période où tout le monde est
devenu plus en plus connecté et nous
crainons que ça va se développer dans le
fut ure et malgré son expertise en
matière de campagne de sensibilisation
du public de recherche et de
développement de programmes éducative
l'Union européenne est toujours soumise
à des cyberattaques constants provenant
de différentses parties du monde nous n'
nous n'avons pas que des amis vous savez
bien nous avons aussi des ennemis des
compétiteurs donc aussi pour
l'intelligence artificiel dans le futur
nous devons être très attentif à cette
dimension mais c'est une discussion
peut-être pour une autre fois vous savez
bien je crois que cétait c'était déjà
présenté dans
euh le colog très intéressant que vous
avez eu aujourd'hui que la façon dont
nous avons abordé
l'intelligence artificielle était d'une
manière de contribuer à bâtir une Europe
résiliente pour la Décennie numérique
euh les citoyens et les entreprises
devraient pouvoir profiter des avantages
de l'intelligence artificielle mais et
c'est très important parce que c'est
c'est une particularité européenne
oui nous
réglementons beaucoup peut-être trop les
États-Unis sont plus euh flexibles
peut-être plus innovatif mais nous euh
voulons que les citoyens les entreprises
se sentent en sécurité et protégé et
c'est quelque chose très important pour
pour nous les européensnes c'est
pourquoi que nous avons abordé cette
question avec une approche plus
préventive en évitant toute menace
éventuelle qui pourrait exploiter nos
système en tout point rien qu'au cours
de la pandémie le secteur de la santé a
été l'un les plus piratés par les
cyberattaques et comme j'avais déjà euh
euh évoqué
euh les les attaques sont euh
malheureusement euh de plus en plus
nombreux
l'approche de l'Union européenne en
matériel de d'intelligence artificielle
est centrée sur l'excellence la
confiance une approche basée sur les
risques dans le but de stimuler la
recherche et capacités industriell et
peut-être nous ne faisons pas beaucoup
sur ça euh mais tout en garantissant la
sécurité les droits fondamentaux nous
ambitionnons une intelligence
artificielle sur et centrée sur l'humain
ainsi l'unen a été la première qui a
proposé et peut-être dans les jours
suivants bien sûr encore des discussions
techniques après et le dernier vote au
Parlement et au conseil mais aussi euh
adopter donc proposer et adopter la
première au monde une législation sur
sur l'intelligence artificielle et il y
a quelques semaines internet global
forum à Kyoto j'ai V beaucoup d'intérê
pass au are partenire stratégique
États-Unis peut-être ils ont une autre
approche mais surtout sur des autres
pays dans des autres continents qui veut
s'inspirer de la législation de l'Union
européenne pour bâtir leur propre
législation nationale et la la loi sur
l'intelligence artificielle est le
premier cadre juridique et tant que tel
aspire à influencer l'approche
réglementaire à l'échelle mondiale et
servir d'exemple de bonne practique pour
le reste du monde je suis sûr de ça
comme nous avons fait beaucoup sur pour
lutter contre
euh climate change
euh nous pouvons aussi euh btir uneenire
inspire beaucoup d'autres sur les
réglementations de l'intelligence
artificielle aussi je finis par dire que
euh le comité que je préside associé
comme à la commission IMCO sur ces Doss
on a beaucoup aussi travaillé pas
seulement sur ces euh euh sur ces
dimensions que j'avais évoqué mais aussi
de donner les euh incentives pour euh
les investissement et bien sûr pour
euh inventer des solutions euh dans le
domaine de l'intelligence artificielle
pour la recherche pour l'innovation pour
innover et c'est quelque chose qu'on
doit travailler un peu plus dans les euh
mois et dans les années qui viennent
parce que bien sûr euh euh si euh
clairement une réglementation est très
important nous sommes dans une
compétition globale et nous devons aussi
bâtir nos propres euh solution euh pour
être plus compétitive et aussi pour
l'exporter dans d'autres partes du monde
pas seulement implémenter et bien sûr
comme était bien dit
euh bâtir des règles pas seulement pour
nos solutions mais aussi pour les
solutions des États-Unis ou des autres
continents et d'autres pays qui vont
être implémentés et utilisés en Europe
le futur réglement euh des autres
réglementations doivent avoir une
ambition plus large visant à faire de
l'Europe sinon un leader mondial
mais euh au moins un des joueurs les
plus importants dans le domaine et si
nous réussissons ça notre compétitivité
dans les décennies qui vient serait plus
et plus euh grande le Parlement européen
a toujours plidé activement pour que
l'Union et ses états ses États membres
exploitent promuve et renforce la valeur
ajoutée de l'intelligence artificielle
et veille à ce que les technique de
l'intelligence artificielle sur sur
centré sur l'humain est conforme aux
valeurs européennes et si qu' droit
énormes fondamentaux afin de rester à la
fois économiquement compétitive et une
puissance mondiale
euh Union européenne doit être de plus
en plus active dans ce domaine aussi et
en époque d'insécurité international ces
systèmes européens doivent rester sû et
résilients ce qui signifie que les
préoccupations tion des sécurité
intégrée vont de pre avec le
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle finalement nous avons un
grand programme le programme Horizon
Europe le plus ambitieux programme de
recherche au monde qui est bien sûr
financé par des fonds publics parce que
si nous parlons de des programmes de
l'industrie ou des programmes euh des
des des grandes entreprises bien sûr
c'est un peu différent mais un programme
financé des public horizon Europe c'est
le plus ambitieux et le plus grand au
monde et euh dans le futur programme
Horizon et dans la 2uxème partie de
l'actuel programme Horizon nous devons
être aussi plus ambitieux et financer la
recherche sur l'intelligence
artificielle et c'est quelque chose très
concret que dans les fin de mandat de ce
Parlement euh moi et quelques collègues
de mon comité euh essayeront de
convaincre la Commission européenne nous
avons des bonnes chances parce que bien
sûr nous avons une très bonne relation
de travail avec la Commission européenne
il n'y a il n'y a pas si longtemps le
Parlement dans le cadre d'élaboration de
l'avenir numérique de l'Europe appelé la
Commission européenne à continuer de
relever les défis posés par la
transition numérique et en particulier à
tier parti des opportunités offertes par
l'universe numérique unique et
par l'intelligence artificielle
améliorer l'isation de l'intelligence
artificielle etir l'innovation les
compétences numériques de l'entreprise
européenne vous avez donc suivi ce coloc
organisé au Sénat sur l'intelligence
artificielle l'occasion de voir comment
ces technologies bouleversent
actuellement le secteur du numérique et
quelle place la France et l'Europe
peuvent prendre dans le développement de
l'intelligence artificielle voilà c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi continuez à suivre l'
et parlementaire sur notre site internet
publicsena.fr je vous souhaite une très
bonne journée sur
[Musique]
publica